[Music]
human beings are everywhere with
settlements on every continent we can be
found in the most isolated corners of
Earth's jungles oceans and Tundras our
impact is so profound most scientists
believe humanity has left a permanent
mark on Earth's geological record so
what would happen if suddenly every
human on earth disappeared with no one
maintaining them some of our creations
backfire immediately hours after we
disappear oil refineries malfunction
producing month-long blazes at plants
like the ones in western India the
southern United States and South Korea
in underground rail systems like those
in London Moscow and New York City
hundreds of drainage pumps are abandoned
flooding the tunnels in just three days
by the end of the first week most
emergency generators have shut down and
once the fires have gone out the earth
goes dark for the first time in
centuries after the first catastrophic
month changes come more gradually within
20 years sidewalks have been torn apart
by weeds and tree roots around this time
flooded tunnels erode the streets above
into urban rivers in temperate climates
the cycle of seasons freezes and thaws
these waterways cracking a pavement and
concrete foundations leaking pipes
caused the same reaction in concrete
buildings and within two hundred winters
most skyscrapers buckle and tumble down
in cities built in river deltas like
Houston these buildings eventually wash
away completely filling nearby
tributaries with crushed concrete rural
and suburban areas decay more slowly but
in largely unsurprising ways leaks mold
bug and rodent infestations all the
usual enemies of the homeowner now go
uncontested within 75 years most houses
supporting beams have rotted and sagged
and the resulting collapsed heap is
home to local rodents and lizards but in
this posthuman world
local has a new meaning our cities are
full of imported plants which now run
wild across their adopted homes water
hyacinth coat the waterways of Shanghai
in a thick green carpet poisonous giant
hogweed x' overgrow the banks of
london's thames river chinese Ailanthus
trees burst through new york city
streets and as sunken skyscrapers add
crumbled concrete to the new forest
floor the soil acidity plummets
potentially allowing new plant life to
thrive this post human biodiversity
extends into the animal kingdom as well
animals follow the unchecked spread of
native and non-native plants venturing
into new habitats with the help of our
leftover bridges in general our
infrastructure saves some animals and
dooms others cockroaches continue to
thrive in their native tropical habitats
but without our heating systems their
urban cousins likely freeze and die out
in just two winters and most
domesticated animals are unable to
survive without us save for a handful of
resourceful pigs dogs and feral house
cats conversely the reduced light
pollution saves over a billion birds
each year whose migrations were
disrupted by blinking communication
tower lights and high tension wires and
mosquitoes multiply endlessly in one of
their favorite man-made nurseries rubber
tires which last for almost a thousand
years as fauna and flora flourish
Earth's climate slowly recovers from
millennia of human impact within thirty
five thousand years the plant cycle
removes the last traces of lead left by
the Industrial Revolution from Earth's
soil and it may take up to 65 thousand
years beyond that for co2 to return to
pre human levels but even after several
million years humanity's legacy lives on
carved in unyielding granite America's
Mount Rushmore survives for 7.2
million years the chemical composition
of our bronze sculptures keeps them
recognizable for over 10 million and
buried deep underground the remnants of
cities built on floodplains have been
preserved in time as a kind of TechKnow
fossil eventually these traces too will
be wiped from the planet surface
humanity hasn't always been here and we
won't be here forever but by
investigating the world without us
perhaps we can learn more about the
world we live in now if you're looking
for a page-turning tour of a posthuman
earth we highly recommend the world
without us which thanks to our partners
at Picador is available at a steeply
discounted rate for a limited time every
copy purchased through this link help
support Ted's nonprofit mission happy
reading
[Music]